to our other top story cars going every
which way on the biggest road project
our Valley has seen in years thank you
for joining us at five I'm Kirsten Joyce
and I'm Brian Loftus it's the Tropicana
Bridge up over I-15 it is now a
diverging diamond endot says that's
supposed to improve efficiency but our
reporters on hand have found in some
cases doing the complete opposite Ryan
Matthey joins us live from there now
with the dilemma and what he's witnessed
Ryan
yeah Kirsten Brian for just a short 30
minutes this morning we were posted
right here and in that time we saw
several cars driving on the wrong side
of the road several near crashes because
of that but according to Nevada
Transportation officials they say all of
this it's supposed to keep traffic
moving in the midst of a Tropicana
Construction
once twice
and so on it's like driving in England
after closing the Tropicana bridge over
the weekend this was put in its place a
diverging diamond which directs traffic
to the opposite side of the road and
closer to freeway on-ramps before
switching back meant to increase
efficiency as drop mechanic construction
limits capacity you know we were totally
lost we we were trying to find the
hamburger place and we couldn't Jeff and
Debbie Cottrell are just driving through
from California and route to Utah but
this was a site they were not expecting
anytime you're on you know doing
something different like you're on the
wrong side of the road I mean that
you start to think okay are the guys
coming from the other direction going to
you know be the same way and get on
their side unfortunately right when we
reopened is when that storm moved in
Monday morning and brought all that rain
and Dot reopening the bridge Monday
morning only to close it again Monday
night to repaint what was washed away
and add features to prevent common
driving mistakes reopen Tuesday with
bigger signs more reflective markers and
reposition dividers don't necessarily
just follow the car in front of it
because of the car in front of you makes
the wrong movement you don't want to
just follow them blindly really pay
attention and understand where you're
supposed to go daytime you can see night
time that's going to be different
but this interchange it's not going
anywhere anytime soon ndot says this
will remain in effect through phase two
and three of the I-15 drop a can of per
Tropicana project rather that's another
year and a half of the diverging diamond
reporting live over the I-15 at
Tropicana Ryan Matthey 8 News Now